all right i am joined now by this beauty
right here miss sneaker martin green i
am so happy to be here we are going
where no one has gone before
this is your first season as captain
that's right he's the boss that's right
she's the boss that's right what was it
like for you um to assume that role and
to kind of you know to finally sit in
that captain's chair oh my goodness if i
could put it concisely if i can try i
mean it was just it was so um it was
exhilarating and solidifying and
cementing and you know fulfilling in in
so many ways and not only is siniqua the
captain on star trek discovery tonight
on paramount plus but she's the first
black female one ever in the franchise
the star trek universe has the most
loyal fans what has been your most
memorable fan encounter the the best one
we were in london at a convention and
and a man came up to me and he said um
he said hey i just need you to know
racism is really rampant in my family um
but i i i watched the whole season and
he said and i felt so
uh connected to you and i related to you
in such a way that at the end i i sort
of looked back and thought oh my
goodness this is a black woman and i'm a
white man and i really
felt like it was me and he said so now i
feel like i can stop the cycle of racism
from the family of course i bust out
crying in front of him and he was like
oh i didn't mean to make you cry and i
was like i what
thank you so much for stopping by please
come back i would love to come please
come back
[Music]